what is the job of the vice president
what is the actual role on a daily basis
as you have found it well I have the
great privilege of serving with Joe
Biden who was president of the United
States
there's only one person who sits behind
that Resolute desk
and the decisions that that person has
to make are the decisions that nobody
else in the country can make and he's an
extraordinary leader
what do you plan to do about crime in
our city a lot
911 was bad
I agree with that it's an excellent
answer and uh the question was what is
the job of the vice president
your answer is what about our traffic
problem nine
eleven
she does not know what the job of the
vice president is and frankly with her
mental Acumen that might be best